bien nous allons parler maintenant de
choses un petit peu plus réjouissantes
en tout cas il s'agit d'une initiative
menée par des spécialistes des jeunes
qui font des chansons pour enfants ils
se sont réunis dans une petite
association qui s'appelle en attendant
le printemps ils ont décidé de
rassembler les enfants du quartier de
belleville c'est à dire place des fêtes
pour les faire chanter les faire jouer
leur faire faire du spectacle et ils se
sont associés pour cela ils ont motivé
les écoles et les parents et nous avons
cru bon d'aller à leur rencontre avec
emmanuel chain
comme pour cette parodie de journal
télévisé
nombreux sont les écoles a profité ce
festival pour mettre en scène les
classes du quartier de belleville c'est
un premier succès le programme est bien
rempli
notre idée c'est un peu développé la
chanson pour enfants qui marchent
relativement bien en france mais qui
n'est pas connu donc de faire connaître
un peu ce phénomène moi je suis revenu
pour les partager en famille c'était
bien
dana dans mon école qui sont venus et
puis je me suis dit que c'était bien sûr
venus chat majeur pour que je regardais
la caisse tout ça c'est super il dansait
une fois ma place est maintenant
maintenant que les vallées terminée
nick end familial
les et c'est bien ce que c'est si elle a
un fils à la liasse l'ambiance
le propre de la chanson pour enfants est
de créer avec le public une
participation très direct cela
représente au bout du compte qu'un jour
le spectacle permanent autour d'un
chapiteau mis à la disposition de tout
un quartier par une poignée frénétique
alimentée par la passion du théâtre
c'est un petit peu long on est très très
peu on est juste 3 à pain avec quand
même des gens comme iaquinta qui
viennent fouiller un bon coup de main et
là vous êtes satisfaite du résultat
ben écoute là c'est le début du festival
alors on veut pas encore trop parler
mais poster de l'animation de la journée
oui on est satisfaits y avait 3000
petits enfants ce matin le sort de mes
coups de ce soir via l'app est alors on
devrait pas être fatigué
une trentaine d'artistes de profession
se produiront sur cette place des fêtes
qui n'aura jamais ni mérité son nom sans
doute aux yeux de tous les enfants du
quartier
ces milliers de petits garçons et
petites filles qui les cours y vont pour
la plupart la chanson actuelle pour
enfants qui va du récital poétique à la
comédie musicale
l'animation instrumental à la danse du
spectacle à la fête